je vois que vous connaissez votre vie
aussi bien que moi Alain Chamfort ça me
rassure beaucoup
mesdames messieurs nous passons à notre
TTO de la semaine
[Musique]
vous êtes notre invité TTO et c'est vous
qui avez composé la chanson cette oeuvre
oui à l'époque c'était pour
Jacky et Lio j'ai fait ça alors
reprenons les choses au départ vous êtes
né le 2 mars
1949 tout le nom de Alain Le Govic alors
pour ouvrir une crêperie ou gagner le
Vendée Globe Alain legovic c'est top
c'est ce qu'il fallait pour faire une
carrière d'un chanson vous avez bien
fait de changer bon alors votre père
était chef de service chez Thomson votre
mère tenez un magasin de vêtements et
vous vivez toute la famille dans un deux
pièces sur cour boulevard Victor Hugo à
Clichy jusqu'à mes trois quatre ans
apprendre à déménager à Eaubonne à côté
d'Enghien-les-Bains
mon père et moi voilà et donc vous aviez
besoin de respirer doux aux bonnes
effectivement bonne réponse je vois que
vous connaissez votre vie aussi bien que
moi Alain Chamfort ça me rassure
beaucoup alors très jeune vos parents
vous mettent au piano vers 3-4 ans
formation classique comme beaucoup de
grands compositeurs de chansons en
France comme Polnareff comme Gainsbourg
comme Michel Berger des gens qui ont été
élevés à la musique classique et là au
moment où vous devez entrer au
conservatoire tout bascule vous entendez
salut les copains sur Europe 1 vous avez
12 ans
j'apprenais la musique classique avec un
prof un peu poussiéreux et tout le monde
se couche j'entendais ça qui me faisait
envie de danser de draguer les filles et
tout c'est
à 13 ans votre père vous offre un petit
orgue électrique Homer avec sono micro
chambre déco vous faites des débuts au
Golf Drouot à la locomotive avec un
groupe c'est normal n'hésitez pas rocker
vous étiez mode parce qu'à l'époque il y
avait les modes et les rockeurs et Alain
était un mode et on regarde à quoi ça
ressemble
[Musique]
il est trop mignon
[Applaudissements]
il s'applique vachement et tout alors
faites deux carences un tour qui font un
bide faut bien loyer mais dans le studio
d'enregistrement vous rencontrez Jacques
Dutronc et vous devenez musicien de
Jacques Dutronc mais surtout c'est pas
seulement musicien où vivait avec lui
l'alcool les femmes la vie avec du tronc
c'est les playboys c'est la fameuse
quand il a appris que j'avais un autre
projet de disque qui m'a avec Dick
Rivers incroyable c'est-à-dire que Dick
Rivers je lui propose de faire un disque
avec lui et là du Tron le vire vraiment
alors ensuite vous galérez grosse galère
vous jouez derrière avec Charden et même
Alain Barrière oui mais c'était pas le
pire honnêtement
d'accord j'en ai dit des je t'aime Alain
Barrière
il a vous rencontrez Claude François
voilà
c'est lui qui vous renomme champfort
vous entrez dans la maison de 10 de
Claude François qui s'appelle les
disques flèche
grosse affaire faut dire que Cloclo
était meilleur en business comme
l'électricité
pas bon on est en affaires non non
quand vous devenez ce qu'on appelle un
chanteur aminate en fait les premières
parties de Claude François alors ce qui
est terrible c'est que il faisait la
première partie quand il faisait la
première partie Claude François lui
donner 50% de la sono 50% de la lumière
et 50% des musiciens moi je dirais 20%
même
alors en plus des coupures d'électricité
de temps en temps bizarrement alerte à
l'avant il y a eu deux fois donc c'est
pas cool vous êtes d'accord pas vraiment
mais de toute façon il n'était pas cool
Claude François faut bien le dire il est
jaloux et la troisième rencontre majeure
de votre vie ce sera Serge Gainsbourg
c'est Jane burkin qui qui vous a branché
et l'expliquer à Serge community pas
qu'un quand chanteur a minette met
excellent mélodie ce qui est vrai et
c'est l'époque où vous faites évidemment
ça
[Musique]
alors au départ Serge avait écrit un
texte intitulé adieu californien adieu
adieu Californie
et il évoque le nom du Manureva et Serge
avait un peu réflexe comme ça de du mot
quoi du son et manurevas sonne bien donc
tout ça se terminera très très mal parce
que vous partez à Los Angeles faire un
disque avec lui vous êtes un mec sérieux
conscien si vous faites vos mélodies
lotissement
en fait vous vous êtes fâché avec tout
le monde
je suis pas fâché mais ici il y a des
moments faut faire des ruptures
heureusement écoutez ce câlin champfort
a composé
petite garce je t'aime
t'aime t'aime
c'est tout à philosophe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ta façon de voir la vie
babyloo
le soir
[Musique]
descend et nos regards
c'est trop la lune
[Musique]
je me vois chasseur d'Ivoire
juste histoire chanson reprise par
Sergio Mendes il y a peu de chansons
françaises
je sais mes troubles je sais mes peines
[Musique]
la quête dans le sang cette fille
méchante laissant comme un adolescent je
déraille bon sens
[Musique]
du ciel peuvent bien m'emporter dans ton
café
[Musique]
dans le caca en français
j'adore alors il y a eu des hauts il y a
eu des bas et aujourd'hui tel le phénix
vous sortez un album intitulé Alain
Chamfort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu